pour nous tous qui parlons des livres à
la télévision bernard pivot demeure
comme une référence
et pourtant il y eu avant lui deux
brillants courriériste un mot qu'il aime
bien à l'antenne
max pol fouchet etienne la loue des
groupes et du mayet claude santelli
mais aucun d'entre eux n'a connu la
légitimité du fondateur d' apostrophes
qui livre ses réflexions dans un petit
ouvrage paru chez plon remontrances à la
ménagère de moins de 50 ans on le sait
celle ci est la cible privilégiée des
annonceurs c'est elle qui déclenche
l'achat des produits vantés lors des
séquences publicitaires
elle règne en partie à son insu sur les
programmes de télévision pas sur toutes
les chaînes ou demeurant la nôtre france
3 ayant connu sa progression grâce à sa
résistance à cette dérive
quelle verve que celle de pivot
racontant ses entretiens avec silvio
berlusconi a le foot ou avec francis
bouygues à l'argent il est le premier à
mesurer que l'époque est révolue où
apostrophe pouvait débuter sur antenne 2
à 21h30 deux nouvelles chaînes sont nés
et la généralisation de la télécommande
à distance le fameux zapping a tout
changé
les thématiques annonce-t-il combleront
les appétits des amateurs du rugby à
xiii ou de philatélie de mécanique
quantique ou de dressage de puces route
ils sont félicités du moins nous et il
est loisible d'accomplir chacun cet acte
arte souveraine s'emparer d'un livre